now to resist bending a hull also
depends very heavily on its keel the
keel is the ship's structural back
backbone so if you think of this beam as
if it were a ship's hull the keel would
be located centrally and oriented
longitudinally along the length of the
beam and if you can visualize that then
you can see that when the hull is
hogging the keel is in compression and
when the hull is sagging the keel is in
tension under a number of other possible
conditions in rough seas the hull might
be subjected to lateral bending in which
case the Q is also bending and it might
undergo twisting type behavior in which
case the keel twists as well now for
long ships in particular it was
generally necessary to assemble the keel
from two or more lengths of timber and
therefore those two lengths of timber
would have to be joined together with
splices this was a significant
structural challenge because these
joints had to be capable of carrying the
same extreme loads as the keel itself
today we could rely on metal fasteners
to provide the necessary strength but
back then the wooden splice had to do
the job on its own to meet this
challenge ancient ship rites devised an
amazing type of joinery the locking
scarf joint has been found in many
ancient shipwrecks and appears to have
been the standard method of splicing
keels and classical airships the
configuration is quite complex but let's
take a moment to look at it the splice
joint consists obviously of two
different pieces of wood now I've got
short segments of wood here but I want
you to imagine that this is one segment
of the keel of a warship which means the
splice joint is here but the keel might
extend for another 30 or 40 feet in this
direction and then for this piece the
section of keel might extend for another
30 or 40 feet in the opposite direction
as well the joint itself quite complex
but I assure you that every single notch
and every single projection has a very
specific load carrying purpose
to appreciate it we really have to put
it together so I'm gonna take the joint
I'm going to insert the lower half into
the upper press it together like that
that leaves a hole in the center but
we'll fill that hole by inserting it
with two wedges that are inserted from
opposite sides the two wedges join in
the center when I Lock them tightly in
position it locks the entire joint
together if I set up a couple of bricks
just for structural testing purposes you
can see that this joint now carries
tremendous bending loads in the vertical
orientation I can flip it sideways and
it carries tremendous bending loads to
the lateral orientation it carries
tension it carries compression and it
can withstand twisting as well of all
the technologies we've examined in this
course I can think of no better example
of virtuosity and craft than this
beautiful joint